[موسيقى]
تورطت الحكومه الامريكيه في انشطه عسكريه
مخالفه للقانون لا ارى انه يمكن
للديمقراطيه ان تتعايش مع استخدام السلطه
في غير محلها على هذا النحو
في اواخر عام
1986 تفجرت واحده من اشهر الفضائح
السياسيه في فتره الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
رونالد ريجن فضيحه ايران كونترا التي تعرف
ايضا باسم ايرانجيت وهي صفقه سريه شملت
بيع اسلحه امريكيه الى ايران رغم تصنيف
واشنطن لها عدوه لامريكا وراعيه للارهاب
كانت ايران بامس الحاجه الى هذه الاسلحه
في حربها ضد العراق ومقابل ذلك استخدمت
نفوذها في اطلاق سراح المواطنين امريكيين
كانوا محتجزين في لبنان
اما الاداره الامريكيه فقد حولت فائض
الاموال من الصفقه الى قوات الكونترا التي
كانت تحارب حكومه ساندينيستا اليساريه
الحاكمه في نيكاراغوا
بعد عامين من هذه الصفقه انتهت الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه بوقف لاطلاق النار في
العشرين من اغسطس من عام 1988
حرب دانيه كلفت كلا الطرفين خسائر بشريه
واقتصاديه باهظه
في السابع والعشرين من شباط فبراير
1991 الحق الجيش الامريكي هزيمه ثقيله
بالعراق بعد سبعه اشهر من غزو الكويت لكن
واشنطن الرابح الاكبر في حرب الخليج
الاولى قلم ادركت يومها انها اطلقت في
ايران عمليه سوف تهز الشرق الاوسط باكمله
بالنسبه للاب لم يكن تحرير الكويت غير
مرحله اولى من سياسه اكبر طموحا بكثير بوش
اراد بناء شرق اوسط جديد
جمهوري معتدل محارب قديم في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مدير سابق لوكاله
المخابرات المركزيه ونائب لرئيس الولايات
المتحده ثم اقوى رئيس دوله في عالم اصبح
احادي القطب بعد سقوط جدار برلين وانهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي
بعد انتصاره في العراق سعابوش الى جعل
منطقه الخليج ذات الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
بسبب ثروتها النفطيه منطقه اكثر امانا
للمصالح الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
ولكن من اجل تحقيق هدفه كنبوش بحاجه اولا
الى حل الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني الذي
يهدد استقرار الشرق الاوسط باكمله بدات
العمليه بمؤتمر سلام في مدريد كان الهدف
من مؤتمر مدريد كسر المحرمات في المحادثات
العربيه الاسرائيليه المباشره هذه كانت
الغايه من تنظيمه الان انشانا قناه ثنائيه
للتفاوض بين اسرائيل والوفد الاردني
الفلسطيني وبين اسرائيل وسوريا وبين
اسرائيل ولبنان وانشانا قناه متعدده
الاطراف كان من المفترض ان ناتي بها
لتوسيع النطاق العربي المتعامل مع اسرائيل
في اطار جهوده لفرض السلام الامريكي على
الشرق الاوسط قام الرئيس بوش بدعوه كل شخص
له اي تاثير محتمل على الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي
دوله واحده فقط كانت غائبه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه
كانت الاجابه العميقه هل سبب عدم دعوه
ايران لهذا المؤتمر تتصل بازمه الرهائن ما
زال الحدث يعيش معنا حتى اليوم
الحقد على ايران الاحتجازها الرهاء عام
هذا ما يقف خلف سياسه الولايات المتحده
اليوم اكثر مما يعتقد اي شخص وهو جزء من
كل لحظه في كل تفكير حول ايران
[موسيقى]
في طهران لم يتقبل القاده الايرانيون
الجدد مشاريع التسويه السلميه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه منذ وفاه الامام الخميني عام
1989 تولى حكم البلاد رجلان من الثوره
الاسلاميه ايه الله علي خاميني كان المرشد
الاعلى الجديد وعلى خطى سلفه كان صلبا في
رفضه للتسويات اما هاشم رفضجاني رئيس
الجمهوريه فكان رجل اعمال ثريا ومقربا من
المرشد الاعلى
السابقماتيا وواقعيا اختار رجلان التزام
الحياد النافع تجاه الامريكيين ابان حرب
الخليج
رانيا لقد ساعد الايرانيون الولايات
المتحده ضد صدام حسين في تلك الحرب فتحوا
قناه اتصال وسامحوا للولايات المتحده
باستخدام المجال الجوي الايراني فعل
الايرانيون ذلك كوسيله لدعم الولايات
المتحده بهدوء وظنوا انهم بعد الحرب
سيكافئون عليها وستكون مكافاتهم تحصيل
حاصل
[موسيقى]
كان اقتصاد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه منهارا
وبنيتها التحتيه قديمه ومتضرره في اغلب
المجالات وكانت بحاجه للخروج من عزلتها
وكانت البلاد لا تزال تترنح من جراء الحرب
الايرانيه العراقيه بين عام
1980 و 1988
صراع مدمر خلف 500 الف قتيل واصاب البلاد
بتصدعات بالغه اثرت على طريقه تفكير
النظام اذا من اجل النهوض والتقدم ومن اجل
حمايه حدودها كانت ايران بحاجه ماسه الى
التحديث
[موسيقى]
كانت اولويه رفسان اعاده البناء لانه
اعتقد واظن ان ذلك كان صحيحا ان اهم شيء
هو اعاده بناء الاقتصاد المدمر لذلك بدا
في تطبيع العلاقات مع اي شخص يمكنه فعل
ذلك معه وبدا يتحدث عن تطبيع العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده
في ذلك الوقت كانت هناك مدرستان فكريتان
في ايران كان احدهم يقول لا تثق في
الامريكيين انهم مخادعون يكذبون وسوف
يخدعونكم واخرون مثل رقص جاني قالوا اننا
لن نخسر شيئا
سوف نظهر حسن نيتنا فاذا لم يفعلوا ذلك
سوف يعرف كل شخص في هذا البلد وخارجه ان
الامريكيين هم الفريق المذنب وليس
الايرانيين
بالنسبه للقاده الايرانيين كان مؤتمر
مدريد دليلا على عدم سعي الامريكيين الى
اذابه الجليد في العلاقات
هل سينقلب السلام الامريكي بما يخص
المصالحه العربيه الاسرائيليه ضدهم وضد
مصالحهم
[موسيقى]
اليتيم
منطقي
ان يفعل شيئا قبل اسبوعين من مؤتمر مدريد
نظم مؤتمره المخصصه لدعم فلسطين كان
مؤتمرا عارضت فلسفته وبنامجه المشروع
الامريكيه بشكل جذري
[موسيقى]
تمكن المرشد الاعلى من جمع ممثلين نحو 60
حركه من خلفيات ايديولوجيه او دينيه
متنوعه وكان من بين الحضور ثوار وقومي
يونا واسلاميون
عبر الجميع عن رفضهم للهيمنه الامريكيه
على الشرق الاوسط ورفضهم لاحتلال فلسطين
ورفضهم لدوله اسرائيل
وجدنا ان حماس والجهاد الاسلامي من اكثر
المنظمات التي
ارادت ان تستمر في عمليه القتال والمقاومه
ضد اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ونحن نؤمن انه لا يمكن تحرير فلسطين الا
بالمقاومه لان التسويه لن تحرر فلسطين
وانما ستصادر قسم كبير من اراضي فلسطين
لذا ايدنا ودعمنا حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
هنا خلف كواليس المؤتمر بدات تتشكل روابط
وثيقه بين حزب الله اللبناني وحركه حماس
الفلسطينيه الاسلاميه والجهاد الاسلامي ما
ادى الى ظهور ما ستسميه طهران لاحقا محور
المقاومه سرعان ما اصبح هذا المحور هدفا
للولايات المتحده واسرائيل
ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه كلها كانت في حاله
حداد
اجتمع ما لا يقل عن 50 الف شخص يعبرون عن
حزنهم لاغتيال زعيمهم
الشيخ عباس الموسوي الامين العام لحزب
الله الذي شوهد مؤخرا في مؤتمر طهران لقي
مصرعه في اليوم السابق مع زوجته وابنهما
على يد الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يسبق لاسرائيل
ان اغتالت من قبل قائدا في حزب الله على
مثل هذا المستوى
[موسيقى]
ماذا حدث اوائل عام
1992 في مواجهه اختطاف جنودها في جنوب
لبنان قررت اسرائيل خطف اعضاء بارزين في
حزب الله لاجراء تبادل للاسرع كان الشيخ
الموسوي هدفا رئيسيا
في السادس عشر من شباط فبراير علمت
المخابرات العسكريه ان الشيخ الموسوي كان
على وشك التوجه بسيارته الى قريه في جنوب
لبنان للمشاركه في مناسبه قرروا ان تتبعه
طائرات استطلاع بدون طيار
كان في طريقه للقريه وكانت لدينا جميع
المعلومات لذلك عرفنا كم عدد السيارات في
موكبه وكم تبعد كل سياره عن الاخرى كما
عرفنا من كان معه
في هذا اليوم وصل الموسوي في وقت مبكر من
فتره بعد الظهر الى مكان الاحتفال كما كان
مقررا لم تكن لديه ادنى فكره ان جميع
تحركاته يتم رصدها مباشره وعن كثب من قبل
المخابرات الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
ان لدينا معلومات رفيعه المستوى ومن شانها
ان تسمح لنا بضرب هدفنا الموسوي لم تكن
هناك حاجه للانتظار ثلاثه اشهر او اربعه
وقد قلت ذلك لرئيس الاركان
بدلا من اختطاف الموسوي دعا يوريساجي الى
القضاء عليه فرصه اخرى كهذه ما كانت لتسنح
قبل فتره طويله الان وقت الضربه اقلع
الطائره مروحيه اسرائيليه في مهمه لقتل
الزعيم الشيعي فور خروجه من الاحتفال
رئيس الوزراء سمير كان نائما كان في
قيلوله ما بعد الظهر لذلك لم يتم اعلامه
قبل دقيقتين قلنا له سنقتل شخصا سال هل هو
شخص سيء نعم انه سيء بحق حسنا لا مانع
[موسيقى]
قبيل الرابعه بعد الظهر اشتعلت النيران في
سياره المرسيدس التي كان الموسوي يقودها
فقتل الشيخ مع زوجته وولدهما على الفور
بدا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق هدفا كبيرا
في صراعه مع حزب الله
مدينه
من وجهه نظر استخباراتيه كانت الضربه بلا
شك ناجحه لكن من وجهه نظر استراتيجيه كانت
كارثه
اتخاذ قرار من هذا القبيل لا توجد كلمه
تصف ذلك كان في الواقع مثيرا للشفقه
قبل اغتياله لم يحصل نقاش حول ما اذا كان
ينبغي علينا القيام بذلك ام لا وحول
العواقب المحتمله
بعد شهر في 17 من اذار مارس عام
1992 انفجرت سياره مفخخه امام السفاره
الاسرائيليه في الارجنتين قتل 28 شخصا
وجرح 250 واعلنت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم لكن في اسرائيل اعتبر
الكثيرون ذلك رد مباشرا من حزب الله
وطهران على اغتيال الموسوي
بعد ذلك ادركت المخابرات الاسرائيليه ان
الوضع قد يزداد سوءا بالاضافه الى استخدام
حزب الله كانت ايران تخطط ايضا لتطوير
اسلحه نوويه اذا فشلت اسرائيل في الرد
فليس من المبالغه الاعتقاد بان وجود
الدوله ذاته قد يكون على المحك
كانت تخطط لتطوير اسلحه نوويه كل شيء كان
يتشكل في ذلك الوقت وكنا اول من ادركه
بينما استلزم الامر عامين اخرين من
المخابرات الامريكيه على الرغم من حيازتنا
الادله ثم ادرك الاوروبيون ذلك ولكن في
العقد الاول من القرن الحادي والعشرين
امام احتمال تطوير ايران لقنبلتها نفذ
رابين ثوره استراتيجيه كان على اسرائيل ان
تتوصل الى تفاهم مع الفلسطينيين فاذا
التزموا بالهدوء يسهل على اسرائيل حمايه
نفسها من ايران
كانت صوره تاريخيه وخالده بعد شهور من
المفاوضات السريه وافق رابين على ابرام
اتفاقيات اوسلو في البيت الابيض مع زعيم
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه ياسر عرفات
اول مره منذ انشاء اسرائيل بدات عمليه
سلام بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
صلاه
عندما صافح عرفات كان رابين يفكر ايضا في
ايران البلد الذي سيكون قادرا على حمايه
نفسه منه بشكل افضل اعتبارا من هذه اللحظه
بعد ان اصبح السلام مع الفلسطينيين ممكنا
مع عمليه السلام اقول لك هذا بصراحه شديده
وصدق لان ايران تعتقد منذ اليوم الاول ان
اسرائيل تنوي الخداع وان اسرائيل ليست
مستعده للاعتراف بحقوق الفلسطينيين
كانت ايرانو مقتنعه تماما ومنذ اليوم
الاول بان هذه مؤامره لفك الارتباط وقتل
الاماني واحلام الفلسطينيين وحقوقهم ايران
لم تكن مستعده لقبول اندرويد
[موسيقى]
قبل كل شيء كان نجاح اتفاقيات اوسلو
بالنسبه لخامنئي مؤشرا على انتصار نظام
اقليمي تهيمن عليه الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وقد تخلص اخيرا من القضيه
الفلسطينيه نظام اقليمي من شانه ان يحيل
ايران الى دور داعم ساعيا نحو اعاده تاسيس
بلاده في قلب رقعه الشطرنج قرر المرشد
الاعلى ان الميثاق الذي تم التوصل اليه
خلال مؤتمر طهران في تشرين الاول اكتوبر
عام
1991 يجب ان يترجم الى افعال وتحقيقا لهذه
الغايه عززت ايران دعمها للحركات
الاسلاميه الفلسطينيه حماس والجهاد
الاسلامي
لقد علمنا في لحظات حرجه من عمليه اوسلو
ان الايرانيين كان يشجعون على تحفيز
القيام بالتفجيرات مجزيه ضد الاسرائيليين
عرفنا بذلك كانت لدينا معلومات انهم كانوا
يعيدون حماس والجهاد الاسلامي ان قتلوا
عددا كبيرا من الاسرائيليين سيحصلون على
مال وفير وان قتلوا ضعف العدد سيحصلون على
مزيد من المال
يعني
[موسيقى]
ارادت واشنطن منع ايران من تمويل الحركات
المتهمه بالارهاب وتطوير الاسلحه النوويه
ففرضت عليها عقوبات اقتصاديه تمهيدا لحظر
شامل يؤدي الى عزل البلاد وتركيعها
والقضاء على خطرها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومع ذلك لن تكون طهران وراء الماساه التي
ستضرب قلب الولايات المتحده ماساه ذات
مخزن رمزي وسياسي ستدشن حقبه جديده للشرق
الاوسط باسره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مع سقوط ما يناهز ثلاثه الاف ضحيه تبين
لولايه المتحده المصدومه ان العدو
الحقيقيه قد لا يكون ايران وحزب الله بل
اسامه بن لادن
جورج بوشلبن الذي انتخب العام الذي سبق لم
يكن امامه خيار غير الرد
[موسيقى]
وينار
حدد الرئيس هدفا الاطاحه بنظام طالبان في
افغانستان الذي استضاف القاعده ودعمها
لسنوات عديده كان وزير الخارجيه قالن طاول
الرئيس الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه ومكلفا
باعداد الارضيه قبل الهجوم باول رئيس
الاركان السابق خلال حرب الخليج الاولى
والذي لم يكن ضمن فريق المحافظين الجدد
ادرك ان بلاده بحاجه الى العمل بمساعده
شريك غير متوقع على الاطلاق
طلب مني
وزير الخارجيه ان اتولى بشكل اساسي
مسؤوليه العمل مع المعارضه الافغانيه
لتشكيل حكومه خلفا لطالبان ادركت اني
بحاجه الى التحدث مع الدول التي كانت تدعم
المعارضه الافغانيه فكرت اني بحاجه الى
التحدث مع ايران كجزء من مسؤولياتي ووافق
كوليمباوند على ذلك
طلب المساعده من طهران العدو اللدود
للولايات المتحده بالاضافه الى وجود ما
يقرب من الف كيلو متر من الحدود المشتركه
مع افغانستان كانت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
حليفا مثاليا لاسقاط نظام طالبان
كاد الايرانيون انفسهم ان ينخرطوا في حرب
مع افغانستان في عام 98 بعد هجوم طالبان
على القنصليه الايرانيه في مزار شريف وقتل
ما يقرب من عشره الدبلوماسيين وصحفيين
ايرانيين لذا فان الايرانيين على عداوه
عميقه لطالبان كان تلاقيا للمصالح لم
يكونوا بحاجه الى اي شيء اخر للتعاون بل
كانوا يتعاونون لسبب واضح هو ان لدينا
مجموعه مماثله من الاهداف
بدا القصف الامريكي على افغانستان في
السابع من تشرين الاول اكتوبر 2001 مؤذنا
بانطلاق عمليه الحريه الدائمه
[موسيقى]
بعد شهر استولى تحالف الشمال وهو التحالف
الرئيسي المعارض لطالبان على كابول
بمساعده القوات الامريكيه وبدعم ومساعده
من ايران
[موسيقى]
دخلت الولايات المتحده افغانستان فقط بسبب
دعم الحرس الثوري الايراني لان كافه
مجموعات التحالف الشمالي كانت تعمل مع
الحرس الثوري الايراني
[موسيقى]
لكن اداره بوش اعتبرت ذلك اهميه ثانويه
بالنسبه اليهم كانت هزيمه طالبان اولا
وقبل كل شيء بمثابه استعراض للقوه
العسكريه الامريكيه اشغل الملح الان هو
بناء افغانستان الغد في اوله كانون الاول
ديسمبر 2001 عقد مؤتمر دولي برئاسه واشنطن
فيبون ضم كافه الفصائل الافغانيه
القضيه الرئيسيه هي الاداره المؤقته
وكيفيه توزيع الحقائب بين المجموعات
المختلفه جغرافيا وعرقيا وغير ذلك هذه
قضيه صعبه مثلها مثل بناء اي تحالف
مره اخرى ساعه طهران للعب دور مركزي وكان
المندوب الايراني محمد جواد ظريف هو الذي
تمكن من الوصول الى حل وسط مع الفصائل
الافغانيه لتشكيل حكومه مؤقته وكذلك صياغه
اعلان النهائي
كانت ايران مبتهجه فقد اثبت الايرانيون
مجددا انهم اذا اتيحت لهم الفرصه يمكنهم
لعب دور استقرار على الساحه الدوليه وهذا
ايضا اثبات انهم لا يستحقون العقوبات التي
تثقل اقتصادهم
[موسيقى]
اخبرني الايرانيون انهم مهتمون بحوار اوسع
قلت انه من غير المصرح لي ان اتحدث عن اي
شيء اخر سوى افغانستان لكنني ساعمل على
نقل اهتمامهم
لم تصل الرساله الى اي مكان في امريكا ما
بعد الحادي عشر من ايلول سبتمبر كان
المكسب بيد المحافظين الجدد حصرا اي نائب
الرئيس جيني ووزير الدفاع رامز فيلد وهذان
كان يعتبران التعاون مع ايران مجرد ترتيب
تكتيكي مؤقت
تولى كل من
زمام العمليه في كل مره تكون ايران بندا
سياسيا على جدول اعمال مجلس الامن القومي
كانتيني يحرص على اسقاط ذلك البند من خلال
تعطيل النظام وعدم اجراء مناقشه حول ايران
لم يحصل ذلك ابدا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشيطان كان ايران لكنه ايضا كان كوريا
الشماليه وعراق صدام حسين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بخطابه حول محور الشر اغلق بوش الباب بشكل
نهائي امام اي تقارب مع ايران هنا اتضحت
عناوين السياسه الخارجيه الجديده التي كان
ينوي فرضها على الشرق الاوسط كانت الحرب
على الارهاب هي الشعار الجديد وكان الهدف
استعمال القوه لازاله اي نظام غير داعم
واستبداله بحكومه يمكن الاعتماد عليها
هنا توجد مفارقه حيث اداه الارهاب مجرد
وسيله وليست عقيده قد تكون هناك
ايديولوجيه تستخدم ارهاب الموظفين وربما
تضطر الى خوض حرب ضمن تلك الايديولوجيه
لكن الحرب على الارهاب لا معنى لها اعتقد
ان الاداره تبرر ذلك بالقول انها حرب على
اولئك الذين يدعمون الارهاب ولذا فاننا لن
نفعل ذلك قال بوش اننا لا نفرق بين اولئك
الذين يقومون باعمال ارهابيه واولئك الذين
يوفرون لهم نوعا من الملاذيب بطريقه ما
لكن بدءا بالعراق وانتقالا الى سوريا ثم
ايران وربما لبنان وربما مصر فان المنطقه
كلها بحاجه لتكون في حاله اضطراب لانها
اذا كانت في حاله اضطراب بين الفرس والعرب
او سواهم عندها لا يمكن لهذه البلدان ان
تتفق ولن تستطيع التوحد ومهاجمه اسرائيل
لذا فلسفتهم الكامله كانت ان الامن الافضل
لاسرائيل هو تعميم الفوضى حول اسرائيل وهو
امر غير بديهي اذا فكرت فيه بجديه لكن كان
هذا ما ارادوه وقد سمعت ايجازه عده مرات
لقد ارادوا الفوضى
[موسيقى]
بحلول الاول من ايار مايو 2003 تم تحقيق
الهدف الاول من خلال سحق نظام صدام حسين
وضع بوشلب نهايه للحمله التي بداها والده
في عام
1991 خلال حرب الخليج الاولى كان بامكانه
ان يستمتع بالنصر بين جنوده وبدا الا شيء
يمكن ان يقف في طريقه
[موسيقى]
عندما غزت الولايات المتحده افغانستان ثم
غزت العراق بذراعي كاذبه وبعد الكذب بشان
وجود اسلحه دمار شامل في العراق وبعد
الكذب بشان العلاقه بين صدام حسين
والقاعده كان الايرانيون قلقين من نوايا
الولايات المتحده لجهه محاوله زعزعه
استقرار ايران او غزوها
[موسيقى]
لذلك منذ غزو العراق كانت ايرانو تعد
نفسها لنوع من الهجوم او الغزو الامريكي
او اي نوع من الصراع مع الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الانتصار الامريكي في
العراق قدمت طهران مبادره مذهله مبادره
بوسعها تغيير كل شيء في الشرق الاوسط في
وزاره الخارجيه بواشنطن وصل فاكس عن طريق
وسيط
تمد السفير السويسري في طهران والذي كان
يمثل مصالح الولايات المتحده في ايران منذ
اغلاق سفارتها في عام
1979 بالكاد بدت الوثيقه ذات مصداقيه فقد
اقترحت اجراء محادثات حول العلاقات مع
حماس والجهاد الاسلامي ونزع سلاح حزب الله
واسلحه الدمار الشامل في المقابل الى رفع
العقوبات والاعتراف بدورها في المنطقه
والوصول الى التقنيات الغربيه ولاسيما
الطاقه نوويه المدنيه فكرت واشنطن في
التداعيات ولكن لماذا سيدعم المرشد الاعلى
مثل هذه الخطوه فجاه وهو الذي لم يبدي اي
مرونه حتى الان
كان هناك اشخاص في النظام الايراني توصلوا
الى نتيجه مفادها ان طريقه الوحيده للخروج
من هذا المازق كانت القيامه بعمل شامل
وكبير وقضينا الكثير من الوقت في التفكير
بما سيكون ان طرحت مثل هذه الافكار وادت
الى بعض الاستعداد السياسي في واشنطن
وطهران من اجل ذلك
في وزاره الخارجيه حيث تم ارساء التعاون
مع ايران بشان افغانستان لم يكن احد
مستعدا لاخذ الوثيقه التي نقلها
الدبلوماسي السويسري على محمل الجد
اتذكر ذلك الفاكس وقد وصل الى الوزير باول
مع نسخه لي بينما كنا نناقش الامر نظرتنا
العامه في ذلك الوقت كانت ان السفيره
السويسريه كان يحمي السلطه في طهران كان
السفير السويسري معروفا من قبلنا بانه
متفائل الى حد ما بشان القدره على حل هذه
المشاكل حسنا وجهه نظرنا كانت ان لدينا
بعض الشكوك حول هذا الامر
اعتقد ان هذا كان نوعا من ذروه الغطرسه
الامريكيه كنا اطحنا للتو بطالبان اولا ثم
بصدام حسين الان دعونا نصنع عراقا
ديموقراطيا وبعد ذلك سوف يعرف الايرانيون
حقا انهم امام خيارين اما الانهيار او
تقديم عروض افضل كان هناك شعور بان النفوذ
الامريكيه تزايد وانه لم يكن هناك داع
للعجله
لطالما تميزت السياسه الامريكيه تجاه
ايران بعنصر قوي من الاستمراريه وقد راى
الايرانيون في الماضي انهم في كل مره
عرضوا تقديم المساعده الى الولايات
المتحده كان رد الاخيره صفعه على الوجه
لذلك في حين بدات تاثير على ايرانه او
الرد داخلها مختلطا اصيب البعض بالصدمه
والبعض الاخر لم يصدم كما ان بعض الاخر لم
يتفاجا لكن ما احدثته في النهايه هو
الاجماع على ان الولايات المتحده في ايران
منافقه للغايه وغير صادقه في طريقه
تعاملها مع ايران
[موسيقى]
بعد استبعادهم من مؤتمر مدريد وبعد الخطاب
حول محور الشر اعتبرت طهران ان هذا الرفض
الجديد للحوار دليل على ان واشنطن ما زالت
عزيمه على احداث تغيير في النظام بايران
لذلك من اجل حمايه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
اتخذ ايه الله قرارا جذريا قرر تكثيف
برنامج تخصيب اليورانيوم والمضي فيه قدما
ومن خلال ذلك سيحصل على اسلحه نوويه في
اسرع وقت ممكن
[موسيقى]
تدايا
ثم جاء رجل قرر تغيير المعادله في الع
لاقات بعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على توليه
منصبه خاطب باراك اوباما ايران مباشره
بمناسبه راس السنه الفارسيه وكانت تلك
سابقه في تاريخ البلدين
[موسيقى]
كان رئيس الجديد نقيضا لسلفه فوا ديمقراطي
قوي عارض غزو العراق عام 2003 وكان يؤمن
بالتعدديه وبقوه دبلوماسيه لمنع ايران من
امتلاك اسلحه نوويه كما اعرب عن اعتقاده
بضروره منع اسرائيل من مهاجمه طهران ذاك
الامر الذي سيغرق الشرق الاوسط باكمله في
الفوضى ان حدث
اردنا ان نوفر لايران مخرجا كريما وطريقا
للعوده الى القواعد التي لم يكن اي شخص في
ايران يمتثل لها كانت الدبلوماسيه جزءا من
تلك الاستراتيجيه لكنها لم تكن العنصر
الوحيد في تلك الاستراتيجيه اذ كانت لدينا
استراتيجيه متعدده الابعاد تتضمن اشكال
مختلفه من الضغط كان من بينها التخطيط
العسكري
كان اوباما واضحا بانه مستعد لاستخدام
جميع الادوات لمنع ايران من الحصول على
سلاح نوويه كل الخيارات مطروحه على
الطاوله والجميع يعلم ان المقصود كان انه
على استعداد للقيام بعمل عسكري اذا تطلب
الوضع ذلك لمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح
نووي
لكن بنيامين نتنياهو كان مرتابا في جديه
خيار اوباما العسكري اذا فشلت المفاوضات
في نظره لم يكن رئيس الامريكي يعرف شيئا
عن الشرق الاوسط بينما كان هو نفسه قائدا
مترسا نتنياهو الاتي من خلفيه صهيونيه
محافظه للغايه والرئيس السابق لوحده خاصه
من الكوماندوس لم يتردد قط في رفضه
التنازل عن امن اسرائيل واعلن انه مستعد
لتدمير منشاه تخصيب اليورانيوم الايرانيه
من دون موافقه واشنطن
كانت اسرائيل مستعده تماما للعمل بدون دعم
امريكي هم لم يخفوا ابدا معارضتهم لعمليه
كهذه بل اعتبرها ضاره للغايه لكني اتذكر
المناقشات التي جرت وجها لوجه مع بوش
واوباما او مع مستشارين لقد اخبرتهم بوضوح
اننا عندما نصل الى مرحله حرجه فيما يتعلق
بامن ومستقبل دوله اسرائيل والشعب اليهودي
لن نفوض المسؤوليه لاي شخص اخر ولا حتى
اليكم انتم اقرب حلفائنا لن نعطيكم ذلك
سنتخذ قراراتنا بسياده كامله وفقا
لاعتباراتنا الخاصه
بالنسبه لنتنياهو وبراك كان التدخل
العسكري الطريقه الوحيده المؤكده لمنع
ايران من الحصول على القنبله لكن قبل ان
يتخذ اي اجراء كان بحاجه الى موافقه
الوزراء الرئيسيين وكبار المسؤولين
العسكريين والاستخباراتيين ولكي يكون
القرار التاريخي بمهاجمه ايران شرعيا كان
من الضروري ان ينال اجماع واسعا
[موسيقى]
من عشبه ان الخيار العسكري كان خاطئا ليس
بسبب استحالته تقنيا ولكن لعدم وجود اجماع
امريكي فنحن لم نحصل على دعمهم حتى لو
تمكنا من تدمير بعض المنشات فان ذلك لن
يحل المشكله لن يؤدي الا الى تفكك التحالف
الذي اسسه اوباما
جاء التصويت لغير صالح الزعيمين
الاسرائيليين فاضطر الى التراجع لكن
اوباما ظل قلقا اذا كان هدفه انجاز صفقه
مع ايران قبل ان يتمكن نتنياهو من اقناع
حكومته بخيار الحرب سيتوجب عليه السعي
لاستعاده السيطره في نهايه عام 2012 وفي
سريه تامه دخل اوباما في مفاوضات مباشره
مع ايران تلف ذلك سلسله من الاجتماعات
المعلنه وغير المعلنه كان هناك اتفاق يشق
طريقه في الثالث من اذار مارس 2015 قام
نتنياهو بمحاوله اخيره لعرقله العمليه ذهب
الى واشنطن لمخاطبه الكونجرس حيث القى
خطابا عنيفا ضد سياسات اكثر حلفائه ولاءا
ورعايه كان تصرفا غير مسبوق في تاريخ
العلاقات بين البلدين
[تصفيق]
كنا نجلس مع الايرانيين وتابعنا الخطاب مع
اعضاء الوفد الايراني لا اقول انه شكل
نقطه محوريه لاربعه ايام من المناقشات لكن
من الواضح ان معارضه اسرائيل للصفقه كانت
الفرضيه الاساسيه تعطي نتنياهو كل الحق في
انتقاد الصفقه والتصريح العلني بانها خطا
لكن الحضور الى مركز الجسم السياسي
الامريكي والتحدث بهذه الطريقه كان امرا
غير عادي على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
لكن ثبت ان مناوره الزعيم الاسرائيلي كانت
عقيمه فخطابه لم يغير شيئا وفي النهايه
كان اوباما هو الفائز
[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه اشهر في الرابع عشر من تموز
يوليو 2015 تم التوقيع على الاتفاق النووي
مثل طهران وزير خارجيتها محمد جواد ظريف
[موسيقى]
مؤمن
تعهدت ايرانو بقصر برنامج تخصيب اليرانيوم
على انتاج الطاقه لاغراض مدنيه والتخلي عن
سعيها لامتلاك اسلحه نوويه في المقابل
ستحصل على رفع تدريجي للعقوبات التي كانت
تخنق اقتصادها بالنسبه للغالبيه العظمى من
الايرانيين كانت اتفاقيه مناره للامل
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنتنياهو فانما جرى كان كارثه اذ
اصبحت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه التي تم
تعزيزها وشرعنتها حتميه الوجود والحضور في
الشرق الاوسط بدات اسرائيل اكثر عزله من
اي وقت مضى لكن هذه الديناميه الجديده بين
ايران والولايات المتحده قد تكون قصيره
العمر
شكل القرار الذي اتخذه الرئيس ترامب بدايه
مرحله جديده في تاريخ العلاقات بين ايران
من جهه والولايات المتحده واسرائيل من جهه
اخرى
منذ ظهور الجمهوريه الاسلاميه عام
1979 لم تندلع الحرب فعليا بين واشنطن
وطهران ولكن لم يكن هناك اي حوار حقيقي
فشل الخصمان باستمرار في تجاوز خلفيتهما
المتناقضه وفي الثالث من يناير كانون
الثاني 2020
تصاعد التوتر بينهما بشكل كبير وبلغ ذروته
باغتيال الجنرال قاسم سليماني قائد فيلق
القدس بواسطه طائره مسيره امريكيه قرب
مطار بغداد الدولي
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق ضنال ترامب
وقتها ان سليمان كان من الواجب القضاء
عليه منذ زمن طويل وبعد بضعه ايام من
الاغتيال ردت ايران بقصف صاروخي ادى الى
حدوث اضرار في قاعدتين عسكريتين امريكيتين
في العراق واصابات بين الجنود الامريكيين
ووصف المرشد الاعلى الايراني علي خامني
الضربه الصاروخيه بانها صفعه قويه على وجه
الولايات المتحده
اما اسرائيل فلا تزال تعتبر ايران خطرا
حقيقيا ومتزايدا يهدد وجودها
[موسيقى]
على مدى اكثر من اربعين عاما كانت حاله
الحرب هي القاعده ولاكثر من اربعين عاما
ساد منطق المواجهه او استمرار المواجهه
عبر الحرب في المناطق الرماديه وحروب الظل
التي قد تؤدي الى مواجهه اوسع تطال
نيرانها الجميع
[موسيقى]